OF SMUGGLERS AND SPREADING
MISINFORMATION.
SANDRA?
>> Sandra: THANKS, JACQUI.
WHAT DOES BORDER AGENTS SAY WHEN
THE LIFTING 42 WON'T MEAN OPEN
BORDERS?
CHRIS CABRERA JOINS US NOW.
FROM YOUR VIEW, WHAT DOES THE
ENDING OF TITLE 42 MEAN FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND OUR BORDERS?
>> YOU KNOW, MA'AM, LISTENING TO
THAT LAST CLIP WHERE THE PRESS
SECRETARY, THAT HAS TO BE THE
DUMBEST THING I'VE EVER HEARD IN
MY LIFE.
LIFTING TITLE 42, WE'RE DEALING
WITH OPEN BORDERS NOW AND
UNPRECEDENTED GROUPS COMING IN.
THAT IS ONE THING THAT THE --
THE SINGLE STRAND THAT IS
HOLDING THINGS TOGETHER TOWN
HERE, FIGHTLE 42.
IF YOU REMOVE IT, YOU HAVE TO
PUT SOMETHING IN ITS PLACE.
IF YOU DON'T, WE'RE GOING TO GET
ROLLED OVER.
>> Sandra: WHAT DO YOU THINK
WILL HAPPEN?
JOE MANCHIN SAYS THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN WILL ASK FOR AN EXTENSION
OF THIS.
I DON'T KNOW.
DO YOU THINK THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY IN THE NEXT 48 HOURS
THAT THAT COULD POSSIBLY HAPPEN?
>> THERE'S A POSSIBILITY THAT IT
COULD HAPPEN.
AS FAR AS THE FOLKS THAT ARE
COMING ACROSS GETTING THE WORD,
THEY'RE ALREADY ON THEIR WAY.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
STOP, TURN AROUND AND GO BACK
HOME.
THEY'VE GONE WAY TOO FAR WITH
THIS.
THEY NEED A REAL SOLUTION AND
FINALLY FIX THIS.
IT'S WAY PAST OUT OF CONTROL.
ANYBODY THAT SAYS OTHERWISE IS
JUST BLIND.
>> Sandra: WE'RE SHOWING THIS
BRAND NEW VIDEO OF A MIGRANT
PROCESSING CENTER IN EL PASO
THAT BILL MELUGIN BROUGHT TO US.
YOU CAN SEE THESE THINGS ARE
OVER CAPACITY.
THERE'S TOO MANY PEOPLE FOR THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE SUPPOSED TO BE
IN THESE BUILDINGS TO BEGIN
WITH.
THE QUESTION TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
IF THE BORDERS ARE NOT OPEN,
WHAT ARE THEY?
WE SEE THESE MASSIVE NUMBERS OF
MIGRANTS FLOWING OVER THE
BORDERS LET ALONE DRUGS POURING
OVER.
WHAT IS IT THEN?
>> WAIT FOR 48 HOURS AND YOU'LL
SEE SOME NUMBERS COMING IN.
THE BIG QUESTION IS, IS IT GOING
TO BE REGULATED TO A FEW SPOTS
LIKE EAGLE PASS AND EL PASO OR
ARE THEY GOING TO HIT EVERYWHERE
FROM BROWNSVILLE OUT TO
SAN DIEGO.
WE'RE IN FOR A ROUGH COUPLE
WEEKS RIGHT IN TIME FOR THE
CHRISTMAS HOLIDAYS, I GUESS.
>> Sandra: WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN KARINE
JEAN-PIERRE JUST SAID THIS IS ON
REPUBLICANS NOW.
THEY'RE ASKING FOR 3.5 BILLION
IN ADDITIONAL BORDER FUNDING.
IF REPUBLICANS DON'T COME
THROUGH ON THIS, THEY'RE NOT
TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY ENOUGH.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPOND TO THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, MA'AM, WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS SINCE 2013.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS FAILED UNDER
MULTIPLE PRESIDENTS REGARDLESS
OF INTENT.
CONGRESS CAN'T SEEM TO PUT THEIR
PARTISANSHIP ASIDE AND GET THIS
DONE.
IF THIS WAS A FOR-PROFIT
COMPANY, WE WOULD HAVE BANKRUPT
YEARS AGO.
THE GOVERNMENT IS INEPT.
THEY CAN'T GET THINGS DONE.
THEY NEED TO STEP ASIDE AND LET
SOMEBODY IN TO GET THINGS DONE.
THE WAY THEY HANDLE THEMSELVES
IS NOT GOOD FOR AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT GOOD.
>> Sandra: WE SEE THE PICTURES
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
WE HEAR YOUR FRUSTRATION AND
URGENCY.
WE CONTINUE TO TELL THE STORY
THE PRESIDENT HAS YET TO PAY A
VISIT TO THE BORDER TO SEE WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
THERE'S BEEN BIPARTISAN GROWING
CALLS FOR HIM TO DO JUST THA